today we went out I'm a Johnny football
guy you guys know that he's an AM guy
he's hit some tough times I thought
maybe we should put him through a little
QB camp try to get him back in the right
mind he's he's making a comeback if you
guys haven't come back yes we heard all
we heard lost in the song anymore we
went to a field drove down West Texas
let's show what happened and where the
plains of West Texas a little football
city Johnny football get back out here
not much been lost in the sauce no big
deal
comeback starts today you heard it here
first let's give it up let's give it up
for Johnny football coming at you all
the doubters let's go
now I travel too slow to a party huh
what what
come on Johnny ball join three all right
so Glenny balls whiteout 583 10 fastest
guy ever seen so don't take it easy
throw them open but a little off from
the ball let's see what you got catch
honey you were cruising and you're about
the size of all my receivers from
Cleveland so we're good haha that's the
best don't get me wrong
[Applause]
I just did like a little worm so
accurate so you're trying to get back
into the nfl's alright that's the plan
the NFL doesn't really like guys like us
you know gree to know that I know that
but if this whole football thing doesn't
work out although I think you're
incredible this workout was great you
should come work for us to Barstow in
the band we'd love to have you I'm gonna
need a title probably like vice Prez but
we'll get into talks down the road I
appreciate the offer I like that a lot
good luck man thank you my friend big
fan Thank You likewise very bland a the
craziest part of that whole video was
after Glen II dropped like his fifth
pass he literally looked at us you said
I have great hands what happened he's
still saying he has great hands right
here osa save the Danny page use Johnny
Manziel sagas been going on quite a long
time we have a little Clancy surprise
for you we have your quote from draft
night Johnny Manziel is bad for my
system I deserve better him his off
you hear that Johnny you're out of the
barstool team that's it
so now and so now you're team Johnny and
you called it though Who am I kidding if
Johnny football booty calls me late
night I'm gonna come running like this
skank that is
but you're a skank I said it yeah I
always say the truth I knew if you eat
called me late night I come running
listen we're four for four with Johnny
being like I'll be here this time all
right he's back yeah actually I've been
I've been hating on him I'm fully
onboard with coming back he's back yeah
Glenny that was something else though
that was I've never seen it guys we got
one more one more
breakpoint up where is he going we're
gonna get one more out throw the
football at him again
[Applause]